hi everyone I just want to say I'm
really excited to announce that we've
already gone past would you believe 9
million subscribers so big thank you to
all of you but the good news is with
fastly getting to 10 million which means
I get my very own diamond plaque come on
how exciting is that 10 million
subscribers so again from the bottom of
my heart and the amazing team a big
THANK YOU but stay tuned because we've
got so many exciting things coming your
way and I can't wait to share it with
you fish lives which means four mains my
place piled high with a clumsy mess of
ribs spicy chicken jambalaya and corn
and bean succotash so tender have to say
so on the plate don't care taste this
might be the first time I should go back
to a kitchen with an empty plane
and thank you very delicious
thank you and you know I thought it's
gonna be really spicy but it was spot-on
they actually made me feel like I was
back at mums for the first time there
are things I would change okay crazy I
know it sounds great I'm sure mine your
head time for a bit of fun and the other
clue is you don't wanna mix too many
colors into the stock too many color
vegetable the stocks overheating so I
take the matter in hand
Willie twig mr. silly I think it's the
earthiness I think it's really okay
tomato sauce even if it's ready he's
impressed but oblivious brilliant
next up lilies shown us how he makes
pasta now it's our turn
finally I want a course where I get to
make something so this is when you've
added too much flour so quickly okay so
it's really hard so he thinks his crap
does he time for a second clue
[Music]
would he spot that as mission start
pasta been made right under his nose
never make Buster before they're lower
your fettuccine we got round blimey
even after all that he hasn't clicked
come on aldo two hours in and the course
moves on to sillies favorite fish we've
gotten prepare our own plates of fish
for cooking let's see what he makes of
this surely he'll smell something fishy
when I finished before most of the
others have even begun some Jeff Scott I
that no I yes
thank you he's never done it before so
the nice hoot owl does miss the true yet
again or has he looks like he's dead
are you sure he hasn't seen these bad
I'm about to get rumbled time to come
clean
mister with it a little bit of Gordon
Ramsay would season them good the ramen
will season them how I seize enough to
cup the cooking because I don't like
salt I can't eat too much salt and good
couldn't good run okay
he's a [ __ ] nightmare and so are you
Jeannot Jeannot Jeannot I've known you
since you were standing there a thank
you I came today to learn something and
you've learned nothing I've learned [ __ ]
holes order French bread as a nap all
right
is that the sports ball or these TV
screens one of those microwaves
how many microwaves if he goes round and
four here and one in there that's five
there's one in there I'm two chefs two
chefs oh my god what time that's just
junk everywhere
well this is cooking stuff just know I
know what cooking suffices no that's
okay
how does this kitchen function give me a
little tour it's very challenging very
very challenging
what sign that that's a burger get on
heating up oh boy
yeah you're boiling a burger I'm just
heating it back up we say he's me back
up why are you cooking it from fresh we
make them another time this is what we
got here we don't a boy burger are you
where the burgers are boiled
ah no do you think your customers want a
burger boiled in water they seem to like
them a new and improved dog kennel
amazing I'm stunned we doubled the size
of these kennels we made them feel
luxurious
we have beautiful brand new bedding when
I first arrived these kennels felt like
a prison now it feels like a reward or a
treat any dog lover want their dogs to
stay even me I'd bring my home dr. joyna
join me triple rum paella
look how gorgeous now this part for me
is one of those exciting parts come this
way please come in I've never seen the
channel with that many dogs and that
many people are you
that many smiles the dogs are here
because we've organized their dog
agility competition Oh No kidding
Wow all the owners and we were checking
and staying in the end perceiving this
kind of event can be done every month
which will drive dog refuses to come and
stay in your stunning Lodge this
phenomenal time sort of looking forward
to really nice classic piece of meat we
have flaming filet mignon that I serve
tableside people just love the chef's
dream
philomene you hmm something simple
[Music]
greeting you from the tile yeah I'm
gonna finish it it's still cooking
you'll love this this salmon this is
butter and garlic
I got it better and so the tsunamis the
garlic butter running down the drain
pipe right you can be honest enjoy it
thank you very much
quite welcome well that's the toughest
most truest filet mignon I've ever
tasted in my entire life
the things are chewy is it so you have
me so tough
yeah no I finish
to me if chef Franz is just another
customer I mean as long as he likes my
food we're gonna get along just fine
good to go rock it out I think he's
gonna love the cell if it's a girl
lettuce
let me can't go wrong grilled salad
in his grills he's still amazed I'm sure
I've never thought about it but it's
true like wait why are we grilling but
it
[Music]
sorry for interrupting just three
seconds but this is a first for me a
grilled Caesar salad delivers the edge
deep grill the lettuce can you just show
a hand if anyone has ever had a grilled
Caesar salad before anybody here ladies
no sorry oh geez I always get nervous
when the chef serves with a butter
lettuce when you've got the butter the
lettuce on you can never clean the
letters properly and unfortunately it's
not very nice inside
dry chicken the salad looks hideous
Jesus thanks them okay wait wait wait
now there's mine now again I have to say
presentation-wise yeah yours looks nice
but doesn't blow me away however no it's
not actually
alright smiles two minutes please
how do you know that wasn't cooked in
the middle but my angle you can see it
sinking in the middle Titanic why am i
sinking dessert finishes cooking three
blind tasters chosen from this evening's
diners are waiting to pick a winner
there we go
something thanks for waiting never they
don't think they do look I think means
just looks a little bit better okay
jean-baptiste wait here we go yeah
good luck thank you not bad I guess mmm
quitting number one it tastes like um
you know brandy butter the average
Christmas pudding that's what it tastes
like to me actually some of the pastries
a bit yeah Troy I think you'd be like
raisins but I quite like these I think
thankless I can taste bigger all dopes
apart you actually think gonna win yes
so do you yeah thank you
well it's completely different very
sweet very very sweet little bit too
sweet for my clothes actually yeah no
I'm much prefer this much me okay guys
it's time for results so I'm gonna start
we've used TV number one was more
preference okay thank you number two was
my favourite
and finally Jaclyn quitting number one
opening number two number one number one
thank you guys and the winner is
we're done : excellent job at ease
how'd he do that to you French franc if
that was your mum that would have made
her win I would have choose oh let's
choose in an investment seriously
yeah I think I think in any uses better
than Gordon name I've never won had you
not taught me properly now that so